In Bakhmut Ukraine.
A brutal standoff
continues as Russian and Ukrainian forces
battle for control of that area.
The head of the Wagner group, the Russian
private military company, admits
that Ukrainian forces
are fighting fiercely for every meter.
A commander for the Ukrainian army
says logistical routes
in and out of boxwood
are still functioning,
meaning the supply of ammunition
remains open for defending forces.
Joining us now
with more on all of this is retired U.S.
Army Colonel Eugene Vindman.
Brother of someone you also recognize,
Alexander Vindman.
There they are right there.
But Eugene
Vindman was born
in Ukraine as the twin brother,
as I said, of Alexander Vindman,
whose central testimony
was part of Donald Trump's
first impeachment trial.
Eugene is now investigating
war crimes in Ukraine
as part of the Atrocity Crimes
Advisory Group created by the US,
UK and EU And Colonel, great to see you.
I know you were just in Ukraine
for the United for Justice
Conference in Lviv.
How clear is the evidence of war crimes?
How is that picture coming together?
I assume it is coming together
because we've seen
I mean, I've seen so much evidence
just covering it on this show.
Well, Jim, there's enormous
evidence of war crimes.
And we've seen evidence in Bukhara
in hostile areas surrounding
Kiev.
But we haven't seen.
And what we've seen so far
is just the tip of the iceberg
is those areas
that are under Russian occupation.
So Mariupol
is probably an order of magnitude worse
than what we've seen so far,
an entire city
of a population of 500,000
that has practically been leveled.
And we won't get a sense
of what
the war crimes in that area look like
until we get access to it.
And what we're looking at
there is indiscriminate attack
on civilian objects civilians.
It's a violation of a major
or critical principle of war
distinction where you cannot attack
civilians and civilian objects
And our group is helping
the Ukrainian
government investigate that.
And you've said Russian
leaders will never escape accountability
for their crimes
no matter how long it takes.
You mean Putin
when you say that as well, don't you?
I mean Putin.
I mean his immediate lieutenants and
I mean the officers military
that are fighting this conflict.
If we think about war
crimes, investigations,
they're long, they're painstaking.
The Ukrainians currently
have something like 74,000 open cases
and they don't have anywhere near 74,000
prosecutors.
So it's going to require
a great deal of
time and effort
and assistance
by international organizations
like mine and others
that will come in and help the Ukrainians
with this enormous Herculean task.
And it's a process
that will take quite a long time.
If you think about the way more to
the Germans,
we're still prosecuting cases
from World War Two last year
and Yugoslavia
which is a few decades old now.
There are cases ongoing.
And so it's a case
it's a matter of documenting
and then being prepared to
try these cases
when the opportunity presents itself.
And last week,
we saw one of Moscow's
biggest aerial
assaults in months
left nearly
half a million people without power.
And Kharkiv.
How long can Ukraine hang on?
You've been there on the ground
several times. Many times.
What is your sense of it on the ground?
Is there will to fight
and their will
to hold back
the Russians
just so strong
that they will bear anything?
Or is there
a time frame
that you're concerned about that
this is
this is about as long as the
Ukrainians can hang on for
Jim, I don't
see the
Ukrainians quitting any time soon.
So, you know,
Russia's always had this fabled ability
to hold on and take a great deal of pain
from Germany
even further back in from the French.
Well,
the Ukrainians are from
that same neighborhood in World War Two.
They suffered
the same sort of casualties.
And they have enormous reserves
and they're nowhere near quitting
and frankly,
they need,
with the help of the United States,
with the help of Western partners,
they can bear this,
frankly, indefinitely.
The air defenses
that are being donated, patriots,
nay, Sams,
Irish teas,
these are things
they're going to help protect the skies
of the.
The missiles that were fired typically.
80% are shot down.
So 20% actually end up
reaching their target
so that the Ukrainians are doing
a magnificent job
of defending their airspace
and defending the ground territory
you talked about.
But it's a grinding struggle.
It's a grinding battle.
Bloody on both sides.
But the Russians are suffering
enormously, much higher
on their own.
Well, Colonel, Eugene Vindman,
you're doing incredible work over there.
Very important work.
Thanks so much for your time.
Say hello to your brother for us
and make sure he knows
that we were able to tell you
you're both apart this evening.
Thank you, Jim.
I appreciate it.